la séance est ouverte
pour nos dernières auditions avant la
suspension des travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui en
visioconférence monsieur Maurice Leroy
ancien ministre de la Ville et ancien
député du Loir-et-Cher monsieur le
ministre vous remercie d'avoir répondu à
la convocation de notre commission dans
des délais serrés dans des conditions
techniques pas faciles mais nous avons
réussi grâce à votre coopération
organisée cet échange monsieur le
ministre le 9 janvier 2019 après une
carrière politique nationale très dense
vous avez quitté vos fonctions de
députés et de vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale pour devenir si
nos informations sont bien exactes
directeur général adjoint du Grand
Moscou chargé des projets internationaux
ce changement de cap vous n'êtes pas
sans le savoir dans notre pays a pu
provoquer quelques surprises
interrogations et même critique et vous
savez monsieur le ministre au-delà de
votre cas personnel de votre expérience
que vous aurez l'occasion de nous
exposer de nous expliquer vous savez que
nous travaillons sur les probabilités
les risques ou les réalités des
ingérences étrangères sur notre
démocratie ou sur les relais d'opinion
médiatique culturelles ou économiques
qui peuvent avoir une influence sur nos
concitoyens et donc sur notre démocratie
c'est pour cela que nous avons souhaité
vous entendre d'une part pour avoir
votre expérience de la vie politique
nationale votre connaissance des liens
entre la politique nationale et les
relations internationales la différence
entre ce qui relèverait de l'influence
acceptable et de l'ingérence
inacceptable pour la sécurité de notre
démocratie de notre démocratie
la problématique de personnalités
politiques mais aussi de haut
fonctionnaires ou de décideurs de toute
nature qui ont pu aller travailler à
l'étranger en particulier pour des
régimes non démocratiques ou peu
démocratiques des régimes autoritaires
voire des dictatures à poser problème
dans nos travaux et nous avons souhaité
interrogé et auditionner un certain
nombre de personnalités qui sont dans ce
cas là ou en tout cas dans ce qui nous
pèse que nous percevons être dans ce cas
là cette audition monsieur le mini je le
précise et retransmise en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale
l'enregistrement vidéo sort ensuite
disponible à la demande cette audition
sur place et à distance est évidemment
ouverte à la presse monsieur le ministre
je vous propose de vous laisser la
parole pour une intervention limée à
d'une quinzaine de minutes davantage si
cela vous semble nécessaire puis nous
poursuivrons nos échanges sur la forme
de question de réponse de votre
serviteur de madame la rapporteur et des
commissaires présents auparavant
monsieur le ministre je vous rappelle
mais vous le savez que au titre de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires les
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
doivent prêter le serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité aussi monsieur le ministre je
vous demande de lever la main droite et
de dire je Le Fur et
je mesure
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre et
je vous laisse la parole
bonjour monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur que je suis heureux aussi de
retrouver
ainsi que les anciens collègues qui sont
membres de votre commission mais il y a
beaucoup de nouveaux j'ai regardé la
composition bien sûr donc on se connaît
pas tous évidemment
si vous me le permettez je voudrais
d'abord
saluant les collègues de votre
commission vraiment adresser mes
remerciements à votre responsable du
secrétariat de votre commission Monsieur
le Conseiller Xavier talon mais aussi
les services informatiques de
l'Assemblée nationale donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'occuper lors d'une
vice-présidente d'ailleurs j'avais cette
délégation et les services de la
chancellerie de l'ambassade de France à
Moscou puisque c'est grâce à la
coopération effectivement de tous que
nous avons pu faire cette vidéo
conférence je serai en France et
la semaine prochaine mais
malheureusement
pas malheureusement mais ça n'était pas
possible de faire l'audition j'aurais
préféré avec vous physiquement bien
entendu mais je vais revenir comme je
vis et je travaille ici je sais que vous
interrompez les travaux pour les
vacances de Pâques du 15 au 30 avril
donc ça n'était pas possible en tout cas
merci de votre invitation et j'ai
plaisir et j'aurais plaisir évidemment à
répondre à vos questions alors
d'abord vous me permettrez la
gentillesse et la délicatesse de te
rappeler mon long passé de parlementaire
et effectivement trois fois
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
je vous assure que je n'ai rien oublié
de ma dernière séance
parmi vous à l'Assemblée le 19 décembre
2018 et je suis pas prêt d'oublier et
l'hommage du président Richard Ferrand
mais aussi de du Premier ministre
Philippe et puis je le dis pour les
nouveaux collègues surtout dans cette
nouvelle Assemblée nationale en 22 ans
on va pas avoir vu souvent mais je parle
sur le contrôle de votre rapporteur qui
connaît bien aussi
l'Assemblée nationale unanime debout du
rassemblement national monsieur le
Président votre groupe moins nombreux à
l'époque et jusqu'à la France insoumise
donc c'était assez émouvant et
impressionnant et je tiens à le dire
pour remercier encore l'Assemblée
nationale lorsque j'ai dit au revoir en
décembre 2018 alors
c'est intéressant dans votre propos
liminaire en me qualifie assez souvent
dans la presse notamment de
directeur général au directeur général
adjoint du Grand Moscou non absolument
pas donc faut déjà corriger ça mais vous
n'y êtes rien vous avez repris les
éléments qui sont fréquemment dans la
presse bien entendu
en fait je suis parti en janvier 2019
j'ai quitté comme vous l'avez très bien
exposé mes mandats mon mandat national
et mon mandat d'élus départemental de
Loir-et-Cher j'ai comme on dit tourner
la page politique nationale et locale à
60 ans à rien quand même voilà et
je suis venu ici ou une grande
entreprise dans laquelle je me trouve
qui s'appelle moshim project et
peut-être pour la commodité je vous
dirai comme ici il parle c'est MIP MIP
ce sera plus facile que de prononcer je
parle par russe moi-même j'ai pas le
talent d'Hervé Mariton donc notre ancien
collègue donc je ne parle pas russe donc
je ne dirige pas du tout le Grand Moscou
je suis
intégré dans cette entreprise moi j'ai
une projet qui est une entreprise de
12000 salariés et
pour bien comprendre j'évoquerai un peu
le travail de cette entreprise parce que
c'est important d'éclairer votre
commission bien entendu en fait c'est
comme si vous voulez les équivalences
chez nous en France c'est comme si je me
trouvais chez Bouygues le groupe Vinci
ou Eiffage pour prendre ces exemples une
très grande entreprise
j'ai en charge dans cette entreprise
le développement
international
de cette entreprise
pourquoi le développement international
cette entreprise il y a 13 ans qui est
une entreprise privée
donc le capital est de du gouvernement
de Moscou de la ville de Moscou mais qui
est une entreprise un statut privé j'ai
donc un contrat de travail de droit
privé et bien que ce soit privé que bien
absolument rien à cacher je tiens si la
commission souhaitée monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur je tiens
à la disposition mon contrat de travail
de vente privée si vous le souhaitiez je
peux le communiquer sans problème je
l'ai communiqué à ma banque je vois pas
pourquoi je ne vous le communiquerai pas
seulement encore une fois rien à cacher
donc je suis dans cette entreprise qui
aujourd'hui
encore une fois une entreprise privée et
qui possède le leadership national en
Russie parmi les sociétés d'aménagement
et de construction effectivement grâce à
l'expérience unique de la ménagement du
Grand Moscou moi je suis projete
aujourd'hui d'une expertise transversale
de la conception et construction des
infrastructures très complexes jusqu'à
l'attraction des investisseurs des
investisseurs pardon dans les projets
immobiliers
et encore une fois cette entreprise a
gagné les appels d'offres des grandes
infrastructures du from Moscou
que sont le métro j'y reviendrai il faut
savoir qu'il y a plus de 100g
[Musique]
et donc cette grande entreprise privée
non seulement possède le record mondial
certifié Guinness du nombre de
tunneliers mobilisés sur le même projet
de métro 23 tunneliers en 2020 mais a
réalisé des sites aussi extraordinaires
que le stade louche Nikki reconnu par le
président de la FIFA comme le meilleur
stade au monde lors du Mondial de
football en 2018 mais aussi l'ensemble
ultra contemporain du parc et de la
Philharmonie de sarriadier lequel a été
lauréat du Prix spécial du jury du
meepim Awards vous savez c'est l'Oscar
de l'immobilier international qui se
tient chaque année à Cannes chez nous en
France et donc cette grande société a
été primée et reconnu par le monde des
promoteurs des architectes et des
urbanistes à Cannes
[Musique]
il faut bien voir et mesurer que le
ce qu'on appelle le grand Moscou
comparable au Grand Paris d'ailleurs est
une métropole maintenant mondiale de
près de 20 millions d'habitants soit le
double de sa taille en 2010
et donc cette grande entreprise est
aussi un grand acteur de l'immobilier à
Moscou qui réalise notamment le projet
de la plus haute tour présidentielle en
Europe il fera 405 mètres d'altitude en
plus des sangards dont je parlais tout à
l'heure un thermodal au potentiel
d'aménagement de 14 millions de mètres
carrés
une petite anecdote personnelle j'ai
résiste pas puisque la gentillesse de
rappeler mon action non seulement à la
ville mais dans la corps historique du
Grand Paris je peux vous assurer que
fort de mon expérience passée de
ministre du Grand Paris je vous assure
que si on interrogé mon ami Patrick
collier ou les élus du Grand Paris les
responsables du Grand Paris rêveraient
de voir regrouper au sein d'une même
structure les compétences de conception
stratégique d'aménagement
d'infrastructures de logement et
d'immobilier et toutes ces compétences
sont aujourd'hui regroupées au sein de
cette grande entreprise donc
et mon rôle c'est effectivement
d'essayer de développer cette entreprise
à l'international avec tout son
savoir-faire et ainsi je m'intéresse à
ce qui se passe
en Inde au Vietnam en Turquie ou encore
en Égypte là encore fort des avancées de
cette très grande entreprise voilà je
pourrais évidemment développer mais je
préfère réserver le temps aux questions
de vos commissaires de vous-même
monsieur le Président et de Madame la
rapporteur donc je me tiens à votre
entière disposition
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
exposé est-ce que pour comprendre
votre parcours est-ce que vous pourriez
nous exposer les rencontres les
décisions peut-être les expériences que
vous avez que vous avez connu qui vous
ont permis de nouer des relations de
travail ou personnel qui vous ont
conduit ou à ce que cette entreprise
vous propose le poste que vous exercez
aujourd'hui j'imagine aussi
partir d'ailleurs vous avez fait des
déclarations vous l'avez dit vous-même
mais on en a retrouvé d'autres à
l'époque dans la presse partir à Moscou
dans un pays extrêmement différent dont
vous ne parlez pas la langue imagine
aussi pour des raisons familiales et
personnelles c'est une décision
importante et dans l'exposé primaire
j'ai pas bien compris comment voilà
l'enchaînement si vous voulez des
rencontres des expériences et décisions
qui vous ont conduit à exercer cette
cette nouvelle responsabilité s'il vous
plaît
oui avec grand plaisir alors
effectivement pour des raisons
tout à fait personnelles
privées j'ai toujours pris soin dans ma
vie publique de pas mélanger de partager
la vie privée et la vie publique mais
enfin voilà
on va dire j'ai refait comme d'autres ma
vie sentimentale
ma compagne est russe et effectivement
le wismère de Moscou à l'époque
connaissance évidemment ce lien
personnel et privé
m'a
marathousi qui était vice-mère de Moscou
à l'époque
j'expliquerai comment je l'ai rencontré
connu etc donc maintes Cosmoline m'a
expliqué qu'il y avait l'opportunité
justement
d'intégrer cette grande entreprise en
janvier 2019 puisque cette grande
entreprise cherchait à se développer à
l'international et que mon parcours mon
expérience notamment au Grand Paris le
ministère de la Ville aussi pouvait
intéresser cette grande entreprise
nationale bon alors ça n'est pas rien je
ne vous cache pas que entre guillemets
de
s'expatrier surtout dans un pays dont on
parle à la langue mais voilà pour moi
c'était le moyen évidemment de pouvoir
venir vivre et travailler ici et donc de
ne pas être
séparés de ma compagne ce qui était
compliqué jusque là évidemment
alors comment les rencontres sont faites
tout simplement
d'abord en 2011
en 2011 le maire de Moscou est venu en
visite
officielle à Paris et
le directeur de cabinet du Premier
ministre le préfet Jean-Paul fauger à
l'époque m'a demandé de recevoir le
maire de Moscou Sergueï sangiani ce que
j'ai fait pendant deux jours et on lui a
présenté
l'atelier des architectes du Grand Paris
ça les a d'ailleurs inspirés puisque ils
ont repris le même concours
d'architecte internationaux fort de ce
que je leur avais montré à Paris à
l'époque
d'ailleurs parenthèse ce sont deux
architectes français Jean-Michel
villemotte
[Musique]
je voulais son nom et
j'ai oublié son pardonnez-moi
de Seine-Maritime ça me reviendra qui
ont été lauréat du du concours
international d'architecte il y a eu
lieu en août 2012 de mémoire à Moscou et
le maire de Moscou s'est inspiré de
cette expérience et de ce concours
d'architecte que je lui avais présenté
évidemment nous étions allés à la
défense à l'époque on avait présenté
aussi le projet du plateau de Saclay
dans le Grand Paris etc enfin bref donc
cette première visite officielle qui a
été le premier contact avec le maire de
Moscou donc en 2011 toujours en 2011
Matignon m'avait demandé d'inaugurer
officiellement le MIPIM à Cannes ce que
j'ai fait évidemment et là le Quai
d'Orsay m'a demandé de recevoir
deux personnalités de Moscou
marathousnouline c'est ma première
rencontre
omipim à Cannes
qui était le vice-mère donc en charge du
Grand Moscou et évidemment comme les
thématiques Moscou et Paris sont je dis
les thématiques parce qu'on peut pas
tout recopier évidemment que c'est et
les mêmes la question du collapse du
trafic routier enfin bref à peu près les
mêmes thématiques je pourrais développer
si vous le souhaitez
et que
les élus de la mairie de Moscou avait
étudié eux-mêmes ce projet
voulu par le Président de la République
Nicolas Sarkozy du Grand Paris et cette
vision historique du Grand Paris donc ça
intéressait bien sûr la ville de Moscou
et donc
Madame accompagné du Directeur des
Relations Internationales de la mer de
la mairie de Moscou
était présent au 1000 PIM et le Quai
d'Orsay dans le cadre des relations
diplomatiques encore russe m'a demandé
comme une liste de les recevoir en MPI à
Cannes ce que j'ai fait pour présenter
le
les objectifs du Grand Paris voilà
comment la rencontre s'est faite et puis
ensuite je suis allé
régulièrement
invité par la ville de Moscou au forum
urbain qui est un forum international
qui avait lieu dans les débuts
ah oui non pardonnez-moi c'est
l'ambassadeur de France Jean de ginesty
on voit sur le plateau de télévision
aujourd'hui sur le conflit avec
l'Ukraine c'est l'ambassadeur de France
Jean de Guinée qui m'a demandé toujours
comme ministre de venir
ouvrir le premier forum urbain de
international de Moscou ce que j'ai fait
à la demande de l'ambassadeur avec grand
plaisir d'ailleurs voilà et puis ensuite
chaque année la mairie de Moscou m'a
réinvité comme intervenant dans le forum
urbain de Moscou et c'est là où j'ai
appris à connaitre
de Moscou et nous sommes devenus
évidemment très très amis et donc
connaissance ce lien privé et personnel
avec ma nouvelle compagne
en 2018
m'a fait part à l'automne je crois de
mémoire de cette opportunité possible
d'intégrer cette grande entreprise
pour m'occuper donc des relations
internationales et du développement
international de cette entreprise voilà
donc comment les choses se sont faites
merci Monsieur ministre durant cette
période que vous avez décrite vous avez
commencé à
remplir des missions que vous avez
confié le gouvernement
puis des contacts réguliers que vous
avez eu est-ce que vous pourriez
analyser donner votre point de vue sur
l'évolution des relations entre la
France et la Russie à tout point de
point de vue diplomatique mais politique
mais aussi économique aussi peut-être de
l'évolution des relations entre le
personnel politique français et la
Russie puisque sauf erreur vous avez
aussi vice-président du groupe d'amitié
France Russie alors je ne sais plus sur
combien de mandats peut-être
pourrez-vous
oh je n'étais j'ai pas toujours été
vice-président du groupe d'amitié France
Russie mais comme je n'ai jamais renié
mon parcours politique de jeunesse
qui est connu qui a fait couler beaucoup
plus d'encre que le regretté sénateur
Pierre Fauchon dans un
la mer Rouge voilà donc tu assumes
d'avoir traversé la mer Rouge j'ai
d'ailleurs jamais renié mon passé
effectivement donc je ne suis toujours
intéressé à la Russie
toujours voilà pour des raisons
politiques personnelles et de mon
parcours politique et alors moi aussi je
me souviens plus monsieur le Président
mais bon ça ça doit être facile de
retrouver dans les services ou les
archives de l'Assemblée nationale mais
comment comme vous savez comment ça se
passe dans les groupes d'amitié j'ai
jamais présidé le groupe d'amitié mais
je me souviens de notre collègue René
André qui était absolument remarquable
président de groupe d'amitié d'amitié
députés de la Manche je crois de mémoire
RPR à l'époque et et à l'époque j'étais
un député qui démarrait donc il faut
gagner les galons faut se faire
reconnaître ça se fait pas comme ça donc
j'ai pas été du groupe amitié tout de
suite ce sont les groupes à la
représentation proportionnelle qui le
détermine mais j'ai dû je l'ai été au
moins une fois peut-être
à deux reprises sur sur cinq mandats de
mémoire voilà et donc ben vous savez
bien comment fonctionne les groupes
d'amitié il y a les échanges avec les
parlementaires etc donc à l'époque
d'ailleurs on recevait même vous le
dites je me remémore ça aussi en même
temps à l'époque on recevait les députés
de la Douma ici au Parlement français et
nous-mêmes nous nous rendions à la Douma
il y avait ces échanges il y avait
d'ailleurs j'ai dû participer cette fois
comme ministre sous l'autorité de
François Fillon Premier ministre au
dernier sommet
franco-russe gouvernemental il se tenait
au Kremlin de mémoire en
oui je pense que c'est 2011
et après ça n'a plus lieu puisque il y a
eu déjà la question de la Crimée qui
faisait débat et après ces échanges
n'ont plus eu lieu donc après les
échanges il se faisaient surtout
par le groupe d'amitié je me souviens je
ne sais plus son nom pardonnez-moi mais
sous majorité socialiste et de gauche
c'était une collègue socialiste qui
présidait le le groupe d'amitié une élue
de Bretagne de mémoire et nous étions
allés nous étions nous avions été reçus
alors à l'époque de mémoire je crois que
le président l'équivalent le président
du groupe d'amitié
France Russie était de Monsieur
léonidslutki je pense peut-être pas bien
le nom pardonnez-moi
le groupe d'amitié à l'époque donc voilà
il y avait des échanges régul et puis
après dans le cadre du Forum urbain
l'ambassade de France évidemment
nous appelait au groupe d'amitié pour
trouver des députés ou des intervenants
de
je suis que Bouygues par exemple a eu
son directeur Europe qui lui par les
Russes qui a participé à plusieurs
tables rondes plusieurs années au forum
urbain
omi PIM aussi parce que le MIPI Macan il
y a eu aussi beaucoup d'échanges Grand
Paris grand Moscou d'ailleurs
Patrick Ollier a participé et il y avait
il y a eu une
charte de coopération entre Nice
métropole signé par Christian Estrosi
omipim de Cannes avec
serviette chez Rémi le Directeur des
Relations Internationales de la mairie
de Moscou donc voyez il y avait
fréquemment je parle même pas des
échanges culturels là il faudrait
redemander aux ambassadeurs de France
successifs mais voilà il était assez
courant et régulier qu'il y ait des
échanges chez bien normal d'ailleurs non
seulement entre groupes d'amitié mais
entre parlementaires et plus des
initiatives qui se déroulaient à Moscou
la plus marquante c'était le forum
urbain
le forum international était un forum
international donc il y avait d'ailleurs
pas que des Français il y avait beaucoup
de délégations étrangères
venus de partout dans le monde
à ça il faut peut-être ajouter
ce qu'on appelle le spif à
Saint-Pétersbourg qui est un forum
économique où là aussi
été représenté le Medef français les
entreprises et entrepreneurs à haut
niveau d'ailleurs à Oran
là c'était moins les parlementaires
c'était plutôt les les
comment dire les entrepreneurs les
entreprises notamment les grandes
entreprises françaises
mais européenne aussi
l'albé qui est l'association européenne
association de l'Union européenne
business qui est en quelque sorte la
Chambre de Commerce Européenne et
toujours présente au
Forum économique de Saint-Pétersbourg
merci Monsieur ministre j'ai bien
compris le effectivement dans les
groupes d'amitié vous avez
différents députés de tout parti
politique qui qui honorent l'amitié
entre la France et la Russie les
échanges culturels les échanges
économiques mais ma question je vais la
repréciser est-ce que parmi ces
personnes vous avez remarqué des
personnes qui avaient des échanges plus
réguliers des intérêt plus prononcé un
enracinement j'ai envie de dire de de
cet échange alors est-ce que le racisme
qui peut être par goût personnel par
doctrine idéologique par conviction et
au-delà de ça ce que vous avez parfois
eu des soupçons ou remarquer des
comportements qui auraient pu relever
d'une influence très forte ou d'une
ingérence par des contrats économiques
par des intérêts économiques par
une forme de de comment dire de
gratification voyage cadeau
fréquentation gracieuse si je puis dire
voilà est-ce que dans l'expérience
longue c'est pour ça aussi qu'on vous a
proposé de demander cette audition
monsieur mini c'est pas juste pour le
grand Moscou c'est aussi pour tout ce
que vous avez pu voir dans votre
expérience est-ce que vous avez remarqué
voilà ce que Tom aussi en tant que
ministre d'ailleurs de la République ou
vice-président de l'Assemblée je vous ai
dit donc cette personne là c'était là me
paraît suspicieux ou non conformes aux
valeurs qui devraient les guider voilà
votre éclairage général sur sur les
relations entre le personnel politique
un exercice bien sur sur le personnel
politique français évidemment percel
politique français avec un peu
d'influence et et les autorités russes
ou les grandes entreprises russes
à ma connaissance non j'ai jamais eu ce
problème
vraiment j'ai beau réfléchir et je vous
écoute attentivement
aussi loin que je fouille dans mon
expérience enfin je vais pas être très
original mais vous savez les groupes
d'amitié ils sont souvent ce que sont
tel ou telle personnalité qui le
président ou qu'il a préside et donc du
coup
même pour un même groupe d'amitié
parfois c'est encéphalogramme plat
quasiment pas d'activités
je veux pas dénoncer les ex petits
camarades même au groupe d'amitié France
aussi ça pas toujours été
ça pas toujours été comment dirais-je
très dynamique quoi on va rester élégant
donc ça dépendait toujours des des
prisons de groupe c'est pour ça que je
parlais de René André parce celui qui
m'a paru faire un vraiment un vrai
travail formidable de coopération
d'échanges etc ça a été sur cette
période j'étais pas dans l'exécutif
d'ailleurs de groupe d'amitié à l'époque
j'étais entre guillemets député de basse
c'était mon premier mandat en 2017 donc
voilà alors communiste non résolument
non puisque
j'ai pas eu à connaître
de ce genre de de choses en tout cas
c'était pas dans mon portefeuille
ministériel
donc voilà parmi mes collègues mais
celui qui était toujours le plus actif
par intérêt mais je sais que vous l'avez
auditionné c'était notre collègue
Thierry Mariani qui était très très
présent et qui faisait d'ailleurs un
gros travail et intéressant passionnant
d'ailleurs de
d'échanges avec avec
comment avec la Russie
mais mais voilà après
tout ça dépend franchement des
présidents de groupe c'est vrai de la
Russie que pour d'autres groupes
d'amitié d'ailleurs donc
voilà et encore une fois souvent
tout ça se fait en général quand c'est
bien fait en lien avec notre
représentation diplomatique avec notre
ambassade et avec les avec les
ambassadeurs donc qui joue aussi tout
leur rôle et qui est majeur qui est très
important voilà
donc je vois pas de en tout cas moi j'ai
pas eu en connaître
très bien merci Monsieur Miss et ma
dernière question on va passer la parole
à Madame la rapporteur sur l'évolution
dans le temps des relations entre la
France et la Russie et des personnalités
amis mais je le dis ami au sens noeud du
terme qui estimait que la relation
franco-rue c'était importantes et
est-ce que voilà vous l'avez cité
vous-même
les problèmes dans le les premiers
problèmes les premières tensions dans le
bon basse ensuite l'annexion illégale de
la Crimée puis évidemment
malheureusement l'agression militaire de
la Russie en Ukraine qui dure maintenant
depuis plus d'un an donc comment
avez-vous vu l'évolution de ces
relations avez-vous essayé de jouer un
rôle de quelconque manière pour essayer
d'épauler la diplomatie française sur
dans ces différentes étapes et
dernièrement notamment avec les
événements en fait pas les événements
les actes illégaux de la l'agression
russe envers l'Ukraine mais même déjà on
peut se poser la question avec
l'annexion illégale de la Crimée comment
vous avez-vous vécu ces événements et
considérez-vous avez-vous considérer un
moment comme l'a fait par exemple
Monsieur François Fillon que vous auriez
dû ou pu démissionner et rentrer en
France ou pouvez-vous nous expliquer
votre décision de garder votre poste et
de rester à Moscou
écoutez merci de cette question parce
que elle a tellement traîné dans
certains réseaux sociaux au moins ça
permet de clarifier les choses donc
c'est le but de la commission
je vous en remercie vraiment
la comparaison avec l'ancien Premier
ministre François Fillon ne tient pas
3 minutes 12 moi je ne siège pas dans un
conseil d'administration je suis pas au
bord comme on dit d'une société
nationale je suis au sein d'une odeur je
suis pas au bord j'ai pas de fonctions
exécutive je suis encore une fois chargé
je suis salarié
donc je touche pas de je tombe présence
etc je suis salarié d'une entreprise
privée voilà qui travaille sur le grand
Moscou
n'est pas raison disait tolérant mais
donc je confirme donc voilà de surcroît
cette entreprise ni de près ni de loin
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas sous sanction
et sous sanction ce qui m'aurait posé
alors là pour le coup effectivement à ce
moment-là un problème de conscience
c'est clair mais cette entreprise n'est
pas sous sanction donc si elle n'est pas
sous sanction et Dieu sait qu'on
l'Europe et les États-Unis notamment
beaucoup de monde sous sanctions cette
entreprise n'est pas sous sanction ça on
ne le dit jamais sur tel ou telle réseau
social donc je tiens le
réaffirmer épargne moi j'ai oublié votre
votre question vous m'avez dit
[Musique]
aussi votre votre vision de l'évolution
des relations entre la France et la
Russie des élus que vous aviez identifié
comme étant particulièrement actif et
vous même votre vision des choses ou
même peut-être vos actes s'il y en a eu
pour favoriser l'imagine la paix
oui je peux
même durant le covid des échanges ont eu
lieu j'étais par exemple à l'initiative
d'une d'une charte d'échange et de
coopération qui a été signée au forum
urbain d'ailleurs il y a 3 ans entre
Patrick collier président de la
métropole du Grand Paris et le maire de
Moscou pour le grand Moscou voilà on a
on avait besoin de ces échanges ils sont
importants ces échanges moi ma
philosophie c'est que
il y aura et on le souhaite tous
j'imagine uniment il y aura un après
cette affreuse et terrible guerre que
j'ai condamné d'ailleurs je tiens à le
dire d'emblée publiquement
ce qui est plus difficile à faire pardon
de dire ça de depuis Moscou et vu ma
fonction que depuis un café parisien
donc ou un réseau social parisien on n'a
pas toujours les noms d'ailleurs de ceux
qui sont sur le réseau social le vrai
nom de cheval
donc moi j'ai condamné cette cette
agression je l'ai fait très clairement
et publiquement voilà
mais je pense qu'il y aura un après et
qu'on a besoin d'hommes et de femmes
d'ailleurs le président de la République
le dit et il a raison je le siège dans
l'opposition mais dans le présent de la
République dit quelque chose qui me
paraît tout à fait juste pourquoi ne pas
le soutenir donc je pense que
Emmanuel Macron a raison de dire comme
président de la République qu'il faut
maintenir le dialogue il rappelle
régulièrement que nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre la Russie sauf s'il y a eu
un changement dans la nuit qui m'a
échappé c'est toujours le cas et donc je
pense qu'il faut des femmes et des
hommes capables de d'être des bâtisseurs
de
d'établir des ponts parce qu'il faudra
évidemment
pour moi la Russie est en Europe enfin
je parle rappeler le général de Gaulle
mais quand même parfois ça fait besoins
de ça fait pas de mal de de rappeler nos
grands dirigeants
moi je considère qu'il faut qu'on garde
les liens
au moins culturels d'amitié vous savez
dans mon entreprise quand je parle avec
les cadres mais même les salariés vous
imaginez pas à quel point ils sont
amoureux de la France
des Français de notre littérature qu'ils
connaissent remarquablement c'est
toujours impressionnant des fois quand
je parle avec des collègues de travail
alors avec des traducteurs puisque je ne
parle pas le russe ou en anglais quand
on échange en anglais voilà au quotidien
moi je vais faire un témoignage
personnel je fais mes courses évidemment
au supermarché bon
si je suis au téléphone et que on entend
on reconnaît que je parle français j'ai
des Russes qui viennent me voir en
disant mais c'est formidable vous êtes
là vous êtes restés tout le monde n'est
pas parti d'ailleurs je suis pas tout
seul faut savoir que selon l'ambassade
de France il y a à peu près
famille françaises qui sont encore là
les femmes et des hommes qui travaillent
comme moi dans des entreprises
françaises qui sont d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui encore le premier employeur
étrangers devant les Allemands et on
pourrait dire la même chose des
Allemands des Espagnols des Italiens etc
heureusement que tout le monde ne part
pas et la question elle est celle de la
défense des intérêts français des
intérêts économiques français donc moi
en tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce que je
pense c'est ce que je pense et c'est ce
qui m'a fait rester en plus
vous l'aurez compris de
de l'aspect privé de ma vie sur lequel
évidemment je vais pas
épiloguer longuement
mais si Monsieur ministre en effet je
l'ignorais mais vous avez je l'ai
retrouvé trace de votre condamnation de
l'agression de la de la de la Russie de
la du l'Ukraine pardon par la Russie
excusez-moi cette agression militaire de
de la Russie sur l'Ukraine est-ce que ce
sera ma dernière question mais parce
qu'elle nourrit c'est d'avant vous dites
donc vous avez condamné cette guerre
est-ce que suite à cette condamnation
publique vous avez eu des rétorsions
de la part du Brusse attendez que
monsieur vous savez que le président
pose la question et elle fait appliquer
la question des autres est-ce que vous
avez eu des rétorsions des pressions
parce qu'il semble en tout cas depuis
notre pays qui exprimait une opposition
aux mesures prises par le régime de
Vladimir Poutine et et les entreprises
qui lui sont liées semblent quand même
particulièrement difficiles voire
impossible pour les opposants russes
je n'ai jamais eu ni mesure de rétorsion
même pas même pas observation
je vous remercie monsieur mini je laisse
la parole à Madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous nous retrouvons donc dans
une circonstance effectivement à un peu
particulière
j'avoue je ne pensais pas me retrouver
dans un tel cas de figure mais le
travail que nous essayons de mener en
honnête femme et en honnête homme je
dirais sur les risques les menaces
réelles de plus en plus pesants
d'ingérence étrangère
dans dans notre pays
nous amène à devoir entendre et
auditionner beaucoup de personnes et
bien évidemment votre très long parcours
votre très long entre guillemets
compagnonnage de route avec la Russie
d'abord l'Union soviétique il y a
quelques décennies et puis maintenant la
Russie ne peut pas laisser indifférent
s'agissant d'essayer de mieux comprendre
la manière dont la Russie d'aujourd'hui
la Russie
d'hier et d'avant-hier mais depuis que
Vladimir Poutine est au pouvoir être
organisent orchestre stratégies je
dirais son influence son interférence
voir son ingérence avec toute une série
de moyens on parle beaucoup de
guéri bride mené à l'échelle de la
planète par un sombre de grandes
puissances et de grand blocs et dans ces
moyens divers qui qui forment un peu ce
qu'on appelle la confrontation la grande
confrontation entre les les puissances
et les nations qui n'appartiennent pas
aux mêmes alliances c'est moi qu'on
puisse dire le fait de recruter des
anciens responsables politiques des
anciens parlementaires des anciens
ministres à côté d'autres moyens de des
stratégies d'influence ou de de
manipulation de des informations etc
occupe une place ce non négligeable sur
laquelle il faut il faut se pencher et
sur laquelle nous avons donc été amenés
à nous à nous pensons à moi j'ai
plusieurs questions tout d'abord est-il
vrai c'est l'information qu'on a trouvé
récemment sur un site
le Wikipédia russe je crois comment le
qualifier autrement que vous avez
récemment à qui est la nationalité russe
alors non c'est pas du tout récent
je l'ai d'ailleurs découverte parce que
c'est pas moi qui l'ai demandé
évidemment vous imaginez
c'est même un ami français que
vice-président de la B qui est un
fonctionnaire du Trésor qui
m'envoie un texto le 22 avril et qui me
dit félicitations
de quoi et pourquoi voilà il pourrait
témoigner d'ailleurs voilà et il me dit
mais parce que je lis dans les
vice-vestias que on vient de t'accorder
avec un violoniste et chef d'orchestre
allemand d'origine roumaine là le
passeport russe des coûts de première
nouvelle parce que je ne le savais pas
donc voilà donc ça date du 22 avril du
22 avril 2021
c'est ça tout à fait récent
administrativement en mai 2021 et donc
la Russie est un pays dont on peut
obtenir le passeport sans l'avoir
formellement demandé
oui oui
ça arrive fréquemment en février il y a
eu une autre personnalité
je me souviens plus l'origine mais
européenne qui avait obtenu aussi voilà
par des Crêts oui tout à fait oui c'est
assez fréquent c'est assez fréquent donc
je suis surprise mais
ce n'est pas tout à fait anodin d'être
juste terminer ma phrase c'est pas tout
à fait anodin la nationalité d'un autre
pays de l'Union européenne
voilà 2021 la Russie le régime de la
liberté Poutine un centre de sujets
internationaux de fait de guerre
c'était déjà produit et tout cela amène
à savoir si dans un cas de figure
où c'est un peu à l'insu de son plein
gré si je vous entends sans l'avoir
sollicité qu'on soit remettre le
passeport donc on a souhaité russe
est-ce qu'il n'est pas envisageable de
le refuser est-ce qu'il faut considérer
cela comme
anecdotique anodin
écoutez nous nous connaissons bien même
le rapporteur vous savez que j'ai pas
l'habitude de pratiquer la langue de
Blois même si la loi est chère à mon
cœur
très sincèrement
je rappelle que on parle de avril 2020
et donc comment
j'ai été effectivement surpris
d'ailleurs pour votre information et
j'ai dû aller le chercher dans une
administration
j'ai pas eu de cérémonie officielle de
remise et tout ça donc ça n'a pas non
plus été utilisé enfin voilà on se parle
clairement donc voilà et j'ai trouvé des
liquide comment vous dire j'ai accepté
je trouvais délicat
[Musique]
délicat de refuser
qui apparaissait comme voilà de la part
de
nos amis russes à l'époque comme
je sais pas comment vous dire un
remerciement sans doute pour le travail
que j'avais réalisé entre Grand Paris
grand Moscou etc donc voilà c'est pas
évidemment aujourd'hui si on regarde
aujourd'hui
mais on est en avril 2021
comme un remerciement je reprends vos
propres mots et tout cela sera versé
dans les dans les contributions mais
voilà pardon est-ce que je pourrais
juste
vous priver à bien je comprends la
vision rend les choses moins solennels
de bien veiller à ce que la rapporteur
puis les commissaires puissent bien
poser leurs questions clairement pour la
clarté des propos aussi de ceux qui nous
suivent je vous en prie madame la
rapporteur reprend la parole et elle
seule là jusqu'à ce qu'elle voulait
redonne
bien j'essaierai de marquer un temps
d'arrêt suffisamment long à la fin de
chacune de mes questions pour qu'il soit
évident que dans ce cas là je remets à
disposition la parole au président qui
est seule habilité à la distribuer je
vais aussi parler
franchement monsieur le ministre est-ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment vous
nous avez décrit l'entreprise
MIP dont vous êtes directeur général
adjoint en charge des relations
internationales ont du rayonnement
à l'étranger est-ce que vous n'avez pas
sentiments compte tenu de vous
anciennes fonctions anciennes
responsabilités gouvernementale etc etc
que
c'est
votre
ancienne vos anciennes responsabilités
votre carnet d'adresses votre situation
personnelle qui sont
utilisés
instrumentalisée et
a-t-elle enseigne donc on vous remercie
on vous remettant le passeport est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas là quand même un procédé
je dirais
assez classique de la part de régime qui
ont besoin d'orchestrer ce genre
de stratégie pour
s'attacher à sombre de fidélité et
s'attacher à sombre de concours
en instrumentalisant peut-être en
utilisant peut-être certaines bonnes
volontés entre guillemets
vous avez la parole monsieur le roi
merci
encore une fois toutes mes excuses
ma volonté n'était pas d'interrompre
mais c'est pas très facile de savoir un
moment donc si on procède comme ça pour
moi ce sera plus facile pour la prise de
parole encore une fois toutes mes
excuses
non les choses sont
beaucoup plus simples que cela moi je ne
suis ni utilisé ni voilà je n'ai rien à
voir ni de près ni de loin ni avec le
gouvernement fédéral russe ni avec les
décisions nationales encore une fois je
travaille dans un groupe qui est
comparable au groupe Bouygues en France
ou Vinci ou F1 je pense ces exemples
parce que ça permet de mieux faire
comprendre les choses voilà
moi j'ai arrêté en janvier 2019 de faire
de la politique nationale ou locale et
évidemment qu'ici je m'astreins
vraiment comment dire à ne jamais
prendre position publiquement c'est
d'ailleurs les consignes que
l'ambassadeur Pierre Lévy a donné à
toute la communauté française qui
travaille ici par mail et je respecte à
la lettre les consignes de l'ambassadeur
de France Pierre Lévy qui d'ailleurs
pourrait vous dire j'ai une action entre
relation avec l'ambassadeur de France
avec nos autorités consulaires et
l'ambassadeur pourrait vous dire que
jamais d'ailleurs je participe aux
cérémonies
commémorative patriotique à l'ambassade
de France où l'ambassadeur m'invite etc
non je et pour le reste
jamais je ne prends position et
évidemment
[Musique]
publiquement donc je ne suis en rien
utiliser par le gouvernement fédéral
russe
à aucun moment et ça pardonnez-moi ici
nous avons nos services que j'ai pas
besoin de vous dire très spéciaux
puisqu'on est devant une commission
d'enquête
je pense
ont dû à un moment donné j'imagine faire
leur travail me concernant donc si peu
le trou je sais pas comment dire je vais
t'écarter où j'aurais eu j'imagine que
j'aurais été je l'espère d'ailleurs
rappelé à l'ordre par les autorités
françaises ça n'a jamais été le cas et
encore une fois je parle sous le
contrôle de l'ambassadeur Pierre Lévy ou
de l'ambassadeur Sylvie Berman qui était
auparavant en poste et qui pourrait
emporter témoignage me concernant je
suis vraiment
c'est pas facile parce qu'on a été
ministre on peut plus rien faire alors
en quelque sorte voilà bon
j'ai j'exerce une activité salariée
comme un cadre supérieur d'une
entreprise et qui ne prend jamais de
position publique niant aussi ni en
France d'ailleurs
alors vous nous avez dit que
l'entreprise MIP pour laquelle vous
travaillez dont vous êtes un salarié
n'est pas concerné par les sanctions
européennes prises à l'encontre de la
Fédération de Russie depuis déjà un
paquet d'années ça a commencé après
l'annexion illégale de la Crimée qui est
en 2014 je rappelle pour ça les essieux
qui nous regarderaient de bien avant que
vous n'arriviez à Moscou et que vous
n'acceptiez cette nouvelle vie entre
guillemets à Moscou mais par contre
l'un des personnages dont vous nous avez
parlé à plusieurs reprises que vous
connaissez donc depuis plusieurs années
avec lequel vous dites entretenir des
liens d'amitié et qui est celui
manuellement qui est le premier vous a
parlé de cette possibilité de développer
une nouvelle vie personnelle et
professionnelle à Moscou monsieur
Marette couche le Nil pour le coup est
concerné par les par les sanctions il
est clairement en tant que membre du
gouvernement parce que je rappelle qu'il
est officiellement vice premier ministre
en charge de la construction dans le
gouvernement fédéral russe et il est je
crois lui clairement placé sous sanction
donc cela ne fait pas
de vous
forcément en raison de ce lien d'amitié
que vous revendiquez toujours
une personne
suspecte mais cela devrait néanmoins me
semble-t-il quand on a exercé les
fonctions qui ont été les vôtres et
encore une fois la Russie c'est pas un
pays comme un autre et depuis fort
longtemps
amené à s'interroger sur le bien fondé
la pertinence
du maintien d'un tel lien élan de prismi
pas même que vous présentez un peu comme
l'équivalent de Bouygues efage ou Vinci
je crois n'a pas tout à fait le même
statut c'est pas une entreprise privée
comme une autre allez je crois
alors j'avais cru comprendre que c'est
c'est son capital et était pas
entièrement privé enfin si tantrique que
c'est notions
existent toujours dans la Russie
actuelle où on sait que des cercles de
pouvoir de plus en plus concentrés
autour du Kremlin y compris dans la
détention de certains intérêts
économiques puissants et
incontestablement la société MIP de ce
que vous nous avez dit détient une
véritable puissance économique elle
travaille à développer Moscou développer
l'image internationale le rayonnement
international de Moscou et tout ça
participe du développement de la
Fédération de Russie de de manière
générale mais voilà est-ce que le fait
d'être dans cette entreprise qui est pas
tout à fait me semble-t-il comme une
entreprise comparable à une entreprise
de de BTP française n'interroge pas
quand même sur le lien de proximité que
cela crée pour vous avec je dirais la
sphère oligarchique autour du maître du
Kremlin
monsieur Laura vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président et merci
Madame la rapporteur de me permettre de
continuer en tout cas de tenter
d'éclairer votre commission et ses
travaux alors je vous confirme bel et
bien que
bien que le capital d'origine puisque
cette entreprise existait déjà du temps
de l'Union soviétique donc le capital a
toujours été je l'ai dit d'ailleurs dans
mon propos
liminaire si on repasse la bande on
pourra le retrouver je l'ai précisé dans
la présentation de MIP j'ai pris soin de
rappeler que bien que le capital
d'origine soit de la ville de Moscou il
s'agit bel et bien d'une entreprise de
droit privé et mon contrat
j'ai consulté un avocat au moment
évidemment vous l'imaginez
mon contrat de travail est un contrat de
travail de droit privé si d'ailleurs
j'avais un conflit ou un licenciement
par cette entreprise les choses qui
peuvent arriver
dans dans ce renseigne un peu
personnellement et bien ça relèverait de
la sphère privée et l'équivalent de nos
prud'hommes à nous même si c'est pas
tout à fait comme ça ici mais enfin
voilà c'est pour simplifier les choses
et les dire et en vérité
d'ailleurs dans
parce que ça j'avais pris soin de le
vérifier évidemment d'ailleurs au
conseil d'administration et au bord de
mythes il n'y a absolument aucun élu de
la ville de Moscou qui est représenté ou
qui siège donc c'est bien une entreprise
totalement privée
qui a un PDG
des directeurs généraux
adjoints
je souligne que je ne suis pas dans le
comité de direction je suis salarié
chargé de mission auprès justement d'un
des directeurs numéro en charge la
prospective dans l'organigramme je suis
rattaché à un Directeur Général Adjoint
en charge donc du développement
international
je voudrais vous soutenir par exemple
c'est un ministre du Grand Paris qui
vous le dit que par exemple la Société
du Grand Paris mais ça on le sait peu
moi j'ai pas de mérite de le savoir
c'était dans mon portefeuille
ministériel mais la Société du Grand
Paris
alors que
elle a comme recette une taxe affectée
décidé à l'époque par mon prédécesseur
et amis Christian Blanc secrétaire
d'État du Grand Paris à l'époque
et Dieu sait que ça ennuyait Bercy à
l'époque d'avoir fait cette taxe
affectée mais il a eu raison de le faire
et bien que ce soit la loi de finances
et c'est vous chers collègues députés
qui votaient cette taxe locale de bureau
sur l'île de France qui est la recette
principale de la Société du Grand Paris
et bien l'associer du Grand Paris qui
associe qui a son conseil
d'administration comme vous le savez les
présidents des Conseils départementaux
le maire de Paris en personne etc et
bien est une société de droit privé
voilà et bien si on compare la Société
du Grand Paris et
la société MIP c'est pourquoi je fais
l'analogie avec Mi avec Bouygues Fages
ou Vinci à la différence de la Société
du Grand Paris le capital est comme
celle du Grand Paris un capital public
originel de la ville de Moscou mais
à la différence c'était des bombailles
c'est réellement privé avec aucun élu
qui siège dans ce conseil
d'administration donc elle est autonome
et indépendante elle détermine son
propre développement avec ses
administrateurs
j'ai encore deux petites questions vous
avez vous-même tout à l'heure
évoquer nos services et qui
s'intéressent bien évidemment parce que
ça fait partie de leur très nombreuses
missions
au sujet des ingérences étrangères
compte tenu des
responsabilités qui furent les vôtres en
France y compris donc au Gouvernement de
la République
n'avez-vous pas
tenter d'avoir
un contact
éventuellement un avis juste un avis
auprès de tel ou tel membre de nos
services avant que que d'accepter
d'intégrer comme salarié une entreprise
russe installé à Moscou et qui travaille
au développement au rayonnement
de la ville de Moscou rayonnement
économique développement urbain etc et
partant de la Fédération de Russie et
qui se déploie dans des opérations
commerciales mais aussi de relation
publique et de rayonnement au sens large
à l'étranger à travers des salons mais
également à travers j'imagine toute une
série d'autres d'autres opérations qui
qui servent enfin qui ont servi et qui
continue certainement à servir une
certaine idée que c'est fait la
Fédération de Russie de ce qu'elle doit
faire pour continuer à exister vous
n'avez pas imaginé qu'il pouvait y avoir
une question à se poser donc peut-être
une question à poser à qui de droit
mais
c'est mini vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur évidemment que je me suis
renseigné quand on m'a fait cette
proposition et voilà les informations
que j'ai recueillies c'est ce que sont
exactement ce que je vous ai exposé
auparavant à savoir c'est une grande
entreprise du bâtiment travaux publics
voilà qui qui
vous parlez de salon madame la
rapporteur très sincèrement il y a plus
d'un an
vous n'auriez pas posé ce type de
question avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine
parce que on peut pas reprocher à une
entreprise une grande entreprise du
bâtiment de travaux publics de
participer à des salons sur la
construction
ou tel ou tel salon comme on a chez nous
à Paris d'ailleurs etc donc
oui c'est le rôle d'une entreprise
d'aller chercher des marchés et donc de
faire ce que nos entreprises françaises
elles-mêmes font ne participer à des
salons se faire connaître et des salons
internationaux encore une fois pardon je
pense qu'on là aussi je vous parle très
franchement je pense qu'on qu'on
surestime tout à fait
MIP n'est pas du tout dans une stratégie
de soft power ou je sais pas quoi vous
savez c'est il y a 12000 salariés ils
font voilà il construisent ils bâtissent
et ils ont rien à voir avec la politique
fédérale peu auproux mais vraiment
absolument pas y compris le directeur le
Président Directeur Général qui est un
ingénieur
il y a d'ailleurs pas mal d'ingénieurs
dans le comité de direction voilà ce
sont des gens qui sont des convertisseur
et des constructeurs qui s'occupent de
la construction du métro de rénover
comment aussi des constructions
[Musique]
ici ils ont un Borlo XXL sur la
rénovation des logements sociaux voilà
après ils sont pas sur la la politique
internationale donc bien sûr je me suis
renseigné et les renseignements que j'ai
pris
me permettait d'intégrer cette
entreprise sans aucune difficulté
et d'ailleurs ça a jamais fait l'objet
de d'observation encore une fois vous
savez je rencontre fréquemment nos
services
de l'ambassade voilà il y a
absolument aucune difficulté ni aucun
problème je parle de l'ambassade de
France bien sûr
et à l'ambassade de France effectivement
mais de manière générale et ça vaut pour
d'autres services il peut y avoir quand
même et puis ça peut valoir pour des
membres de leur présentation nationale
des interrogations quand au bien fondé
de choix professionnels de ce type quand
on a été ancien ministre ou qu'on a
exerçait de d'autres fonctions
dans l'état français et là je parle
d'une époque qui précède même l'invasion
guerrière de l'Ukraine par la Fédération
de de Russie mais bon je vais pas je
vais pas prolonger là-dessus parce que
je pense que d'autres
collègues veulent prendre la parole je
voulais juste laisser mon ma dernière
intervention monsieur le Président vous
avez monsieur
Maurice Leroy monsieur le ministre
parler de garder les liens avoir des
ponts pour l'avenir
avec la Russie
évoquait même la défense des intérêts
économiques français dont vous seriez si
je vous ai compris en quelque sorte
partie prenante en exerçant les
fonctions que vous exercez en ayant
accepté d'entrer comme salarié enfin
vous avez employé l'expression de
défense des intérêts économiques
français c'était ce à quoi vous
accordiez de l'importance et ce à quoi
vous vous attachiez dans un
développement où il y avait à la fois
l'idée de voilà de du dialogue de garder
les liens de bâtir des ponts etc voilà
donc je voulais simplement être sûr que
que j'avais bien entendu ce que vous
aviez dit
s'agissant de la défense des intérêts
économiques français
monsieur mini vous avez la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président oui je
encore une fois au risque de me répéter
ici
nos entreprises françaises je pense
qu'on devrait enfin je sais pas en
français on devrait s'en réjouir je
parle devant la représentation nationale
dans laquelle je me suis trouvé moi-même
pendant 22 ans
[Musique]
alors est-ce qu'il faut que nos
entreprises françaises quittent la Chine
puisque tout le monde sait combien ce
régime est absolument démocratique etc
donc
pourquoi le président de la République
va rencontrer le président
et donc voilà c'est quand même une
question fondamentale quand je dis la
défense des intérêts français oui
effectivement
vous savez le jour où
si ça arrive ou Auchan où le roi Merlin
qui sont des fleurons français ici
quitte vous savez qu'il va reprendre
voilà
sans doute Alibaba ou des entreprises
chinoises etc on fera quoi après on fera
une nouvelle commission
d'enquête pour voir comment on a perdu
les parts de marché les places etc c'est
ça que je veux évoquer
comment notre collègue Anne John T qui
est député de cette circonscription
qu'elle connaît bien
a eu l'occasion régulièrement de
rencontrer nos chefs dans nos dirigeants
de l'entreprise etc donc c'est c'est pas
rien d'être le premier employeur
étranger ici
le jour au champ fermera où le jour
Leroy Merlin fermera
ça touchera les emplois en France ça
touchera les emplois en France
fatalement donc
quand je parle de défendre les intérêts
français oui j'assume ou bien de
défendre les intérêts français merci
Monsieur
à vous poser
oui la dernière est-ce que vous
connaissez Charles d'Anjou
la nature des relations que vous
entretenez avec Charles d'Anjou
j'ai connu Charles d'Anjou il y a
plusieurs temps j'ai perdu sa trace
depuis mais j'ai croisé effectivement
Charles d'Anjou quand justement il était
responsable
de la sécurité du groupe Leroy Merlin
effectivement mais après
je sais qu'il est reparti en France vers
d'autres horizons donc je n'ai plus de
je n'ai plus de lien avec Charles
d'Anjou mais je l'ai connu à Moscou et
croisé dans des cérémonies évidemment à
l'ambassade de France ou au sein de la
communauté d'affaires françaises
effectivement
merci Monsieur Miss pour la bonne tenue
de cette commission est-ce que quand
vous parlez d'un temps pour la question
qui vous a été posée par Madame la
rapporteur sur monsieur d'Anjou il se
trouve que nous l'auditionnons aussi
après donc cette question est un intérêt
particulier est-ce que vous parlez de
février 2019 puisque nos modestes ont
investigation nous ont permis de
d'identifier une photo vous êtes en sa
compagnie à Moscou avec Monsieur Gérald
Dautier le 8 février 2019 donc est-ce
que c'est ce temps-là vous faisiez
mention ou est-ce que vous parlez de
temps plus ancien ou plus récent
Gérald Authier est un
financier je crois enfin je sais pas
bien son titre exact effectivement et on
a dîné ensemble à Moscou
tout à fait normalement à cette période
là tout à fait mais ça doit être depuis
ce moment d'ailleurs que j'ai pu trop bu
de nouvelles mais à l'époque il était
responsable de la sécurité du groupe
Leroy Merlin
ou adjoint au responsable chez nous
je vous remercie monsieur ministre vous
avez une question de Monsieur escape
président de la Commission
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers de nous
croiser puisque je suis un nouveau
député merci pour votre exposé je dois
dire en amont de mes questions que j'ai
du respect pour votre parcours politique
qui vous a mené du Parti communiste au
Parti du Centre donc je fais partie
une question
voilà donc
pour des choses un peu plus proches de
notre sujet dans le contexte de guerre
en Ukraine alors je rebondis un peu sur
la question de
la rapporteur et j'insiste sur ce
contexte de guerre en Ukraine comment
justifier vous de travailler pour un
projet avec un objectif de promotion de
Moscou puisque il s'agit quand même de
promouvoir la ville de Moscou et de
servir de ce fait les intérêts des
intérêts de l'économie russe
sur ce sujet un autre ministre et
d'ailleurs même le premier Monsieur
François Fillon tout d'abord réticent
quitter son poste à quand même fini par
démissionner devant la valence de
critiques votre nationalité française et
votre parcours politique qui est certes
très respectable je l'ai dit ne sont-ils
pas un faire-valoir pour le pouvoir
russe pour se rendre présentable aux
yeux de l'international voilà ma
première question
de la Commission comme on a dit
dans la règle du jeu de distribue la
parole
d'abord merci à
chers collègues effectivement c'est pas
connu mais voilà ça fait plaisir de
pouvoir vous retrouver puisque on était
je pense dans la même formation
politique en tout cas dans la famille
dans la même famille du centre voilà
même si c'est pas la même formation
non je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure en
réponse à Madame la rapporteur je ne
suis en rien
faire valoir et ça encore une fois nos
autorités françaises pourront
porter témoignage de cela
en n'utilise pas je ne suis pas mis en
avant je serais mis en avant je
comprendrais et encore une fois
je ne siège pas au bord
d'une société nationale d'accord donc
encore une fois
ça n'a strictement rien à voir donc j'ai
déjà répondu à ces questions ça n'a pas
du tout c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout la même chose je suis pas Gerard
Schroeder qui qui était au bord qui
venait une fois par mois voilà moi c'est
pas mon cas je vis et je travaille
depuis janvier 2019
à Moscou donc je ne suis faire valoir
franchement de de personnes voilà
merci Monsieur ministre juste avant de
redonner la parole à ce président sa
question m'inspire une peut-être une
précision monsieur mise pour qu'on
comprenne et que surtout parce que c'est
le but et vous le savez bien en tant que
service président de l'Assemblée de ces
commissions d'encaisse et d'éclairer la
représentation nationale mais aussi nos
concitoyens quand vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas à faire valoir ce dont ce que
j'entends est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être préciser ce qu'on pourrait
entendre par cela vous n'êtes pas invité
à des cérémonies en tant qu'enseignant
ministre français
à des cérémonies du régime russe ou de
la de la mairie de Moscou ou de
l'établissement du Grand Moscou vous
n'êtes pas présenté dans ces occasions
comme un ancien ministre vous n'êtes pas
voilà votre fonction c'est une question
ouverte moi je n'ai pas je ne parle pas
russe non plus donc je n'ai pas les
moyens de consulter les médias reçus
vous n'êtes pas
vous n'avez pas vous n'êtes pas là vous
n'êtes pas utilisé d'une quelconque
manière pas forcément manipuler juste
valoriser dans les médias russe non pas
forcément pour la propagande russe à
l'extérieur mais peut-être pour la
communication ou la propagande russe au
sein de leur propre pays pour dire
regardez on a une personnalité qualifiée
étrangère qui travaille avec une
entreprise une entreprise russe qui a
une grande mission pour la prospérité
russe je pense que c'est peut-être la
précision je vous demande d'apporter
peut-être plus éclairante pour pour
savoir de quoi on parle
vous avez la parole
merci Monsieur le Précis monsieur le
Président
les seules cérémonies publiques
ou privé auquel j'assiste et c'est
facilement vérifiable par les services
de l'ambassade de France les seuls
cérémonies auxquelles je participe sont
celles du 8 mai prochainement d'ailleurs
du 11 novembre du 14 juillet les
cérémonies traditionnelles patriotiques
commémorative qui sont à l'ambassade de
France je ne suis jamais invité
d'ailleurs personnellement j'ai aucune
raison d'être d'ailleurs puisque je ne
suis pas employé par la mairie de Moscou
donc
je ne suis jamais invité en aucune façon
dans des cérémonies russes en plus je ne
parle pas russe donc voilà donc je ne
suis jamais invité moi j'ai ma vie de je
sais pas comment dire comme un cadre
supérieur salariés alors certes j'étais
en fiabilise d'accord
et ben
je ne suis pas ni utilisé et quant aux
médias russes on me voit jamais dans les
médias russes et pour cause voilà donc
plus donc je ne suis pas du tout utilisé
voilà
merci Monsieur mille pour ces précisions
étaient utiles monsieur esquennégov ça a
une seconde question
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
précédente je précise que le 8 mai c'est
aussi une fête russe il me semble mais
donc c'est le 10 peut-être ah c'est le 9
ok bon passons monsieur le ministre le
12 février 2022 vous avez partagé un
tweet de l'ambassade de Russie à Paris
qui accusait les médias occidentaux et
ceci quelques jours avant l'évasion
russe de désinformation sur les
intentions de la Russie en Ukraine j'ai
sous les yeux ce fasciner il s'agit
effectivement d'un tweet Maurice Leroy
rue Twitter Russie en France exemple de
publication de la Vasse campagne de
désinformation des médias occidentaux
propageant la thèse d'une prétendue
invasion de l'Ukraine quelques jours
avant l'invasion par la Russie en
préparation pouvez-vous revenir sur ce
tweet les raisons qui vous ont poussé à
le faire êtes-vous toujours en accord
avec ce retweet
et où regrettez-vous au contraire les
agissements de ceux ou de celles qui
vous ont contribué à relayer la
propagande du Kremlin merci
excusez-moi monsieur ministre vous avez
la parole
pas de souci monsieur le Président
écoutez oui je regrette d'avoir retweeté
cela d'ailleurs vous pouvez pas m'en
citer ensuite
quant au fait que c'était peu de temps
avant pardon mais franchement je
pourrais vous citer une liste
impressionnante vous aussi d'ailleurs
mon chers collègue de gens qui comme moi
pensaient que ce serait que cette
invasion serait impossible et n'aurait
jamais lieu donc voilà même
au plus haut sommet de notre État
français mais je dois reconnaître que je
regrette d'avoir fait ce retweet à
l'époque et je n'aurais pas dû le faire
que les choses soient claires
mais il arrive qu'on fasse des bêtises
voilà ça arrive je suis pas un bébé
éprouvette donc je n'aurais pas dû faire
ce retweet c'est tout à fait exact
j'entends vos regrets et non je peux
vous confirmer que quelques jours avant
on était beaucoup avoir des certitudes
sur l'invasion russe puisque les troupes
se masser par milliers à la frontière je
vous remercie
je me permets de relancer sur la
question du vice-président parce qu'il
vous a demandé je parle sur son contrôle
qu'est-ce qui vous avez poussé à le
faire alors ne vous avez dit que c'était
une bêtise mais vous confirmez parce que
moi j'aime pas qu'elle est sous-entendus
dans une commission qui joue les sujets
sensibles personne ne vous a demandé de
de
d'intervenir personne vous a sollicité
vous êtes pas sorti de manière ou d'une
autre obligée de communiquer pour que ce
soit clair de dans les faits établi par
cette commission
merci de votre demande
d'éclaircissements que je fais
volontiers avec non non j'ai vraiment
fait cette bourde et cette bêtise tout
seul sans la vie de personne d'ailleurs
il y a personne ce qui me connaissent ou
qui m'ont connu savent que
je suis pas du tout du style même dans
mon propre parti à avoir le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon jamais été mon style
donc non non les choses sont simples ils
m'arrivaient de relier on a relevé ce
truc là mais il m'est arrivé parfois de
relayer d'autres tweets et hélas des
fois on fait des choses un peu
mécaniquement et je dois reconnaître que
c'était une une faute de ma part et à
tout le moins une erreur mais commise
évidemment tout seul il a jamais
personne qui me tient la main pour pour
dire de faire ceci ou faire cela c'est
pas du tout mon style
vous savez ici
juste pour une anecdote pour ceux qui me
connaissent pas moi j'ai voté contre le
quinquennat à l'époque ici à l'Assemblée
nationale j'avais le pouvoir de Raymond
Barre à l'époque et malgré les
injonctions du président
paix à son âme de François Bayou et
d'autres qui faisait injonction de de
voter en faveur du quinquennat j'ai voté
contre et vous pouvez revoir le scrutin
public nous n'étions pas nombreux
surtout les bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale à avoir voté contre le
quinquennat donc je suis pas quelqu'un
qui se laisse dicter pas plus en France
qu'ailleurs les choses j'ai fait cette
j'ai commis cette erreur tout seul sans
personne
dans la vie présente genete
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ravi de vous
retrouver après vous avoir rencontré en
effet à Moscou depuis que vous y avez
pris vos fonctions
je
tiens-moi rapide en effet je connais
bien les présences françaises
en Russie la situation est plus complexe
que beaucoup ne peuvent l'imaginer et
vous l'avez dit je crois que laisser une
place vie n'est pas forcément la
meilleure des solutions chaque
entreprise d'ailleurs à trouver sa
manière de gérer une situation
infiniment complexe dans une situation
clairement il faut le répéter la France
condamne l'agression de la Russie sur
l'Ukraine et ça il faut jamais l'oublier
et je n'ai pas de doute sur le fait que
la plupart de nos entreprises en tout
cas leur siège sociaux en France
condamne également cette invasion vous
avez répété à plusieurs reprises que
donc vous ne parlez pas russe
vous avez décrit votre entreprise mis
comme une entreprise de bâtisseurs
d'ingénieurs vous même vous avez un
parcours je crois pas que vous soyez
vous ayez vous-même à bâtisseurs en
ingénieur mais vous êtes plutôt du
sur un parcours très politique vous êtes
vous-même dans la description de votre
poste en charge du développement donc
moi j'aimerais quand même comprendre
qu'est-ce qui a donné l'idée aux Russes
de cette entreprise mis de vous choisir
vous français qui ne parlait pas russe
qui n'avait pas d'expérience de
bâtisseurs même si vous avez une
expérience en politique de la ville
communiste mais c'est une expérience
politique c'est pas une expérience
technique qu'est-ce qui a donné à l'idée
qu'est-ce qui a motivé la partie russe
de l'entreprise MIP pour aller vous
chercher vous elle aurait pu aller vous
demander conseil vous faire travailler
comme consultant faire travailler sur un
projet temporaire ça se fait beaucoup
vous demandez votre avis et puis après
techniquement pour développer la société
pour développer ses relations
internationales je crois que vous c'est
aussi dans votre périmètre embaucher un
Russe qui est lui du coup par le Russe
peut interagir avec les différentes
parties parce que j'imagine que ça n'est
pas forcément évident pour vous de
communiquer avec avec vos collègues et
avec votre environnement donc qu'est-ce
qui a motivé les Russes pour aller
choisir un français et un politique
et un politique expérimenté pour tenir
la fonction vous occupez aujourd'hui
comprenez que ça puisse quand même
interroger notre commission
vous avez la parole
merci chers
rencontré à Moscou
[Musique]
d'abord je partage vraiment ce que vous
avez dit je le dis pour vos collègues il
faut entendre ce que dit votre collègue
Anne Gentet qui est exactement ce que
j'ai exprimé ou en tout cas voulu
exprimer tout à l'heure quand je parlais
des intérêts français à Moscou
c'est une très très bonne question cher
Anne je ne t'ai qu'est-ce qui a motivé
cette entreprise à me recruter pour le
développement international je vais vous
le dire
cette entreprise
a changé de direction générale
à ce moment là et
cette direction générale a eu conscience
il y a eu toute une des nouveaux
directeurs généraux et
ce sont des gens qui parlent anglais
c'est pas tous les Russes qui parlent
anglais je vous assure on peut paraître
surprenant mais c'est le cas donc même
si je parle par russe nous parlons en
anglais
dans dans
notamment le directeur général adjoint
auquel je suis rattaché avec un champ de
la prospective de cette
grande société privée
nous nous exprimons en anglais
vous savez la langue n'est pas un
problème il suffit d'avoir un interprète
c'est le cas quand il y a des réunions
très techniques il y a un interprète qui
évidemment traduit donc ça pose pas de
difficultés et pour le reste comme j'ai
en charge le développement international
grâce à l'anglais et ma pratique de
l'anglais ça du coup il y a pas de
barrière de la lampe c'est très
intéressant parce que cette entreprise
qui veut se développer à l'international
elle a parfaitement conscience que
comment dire ils ont besoin de
travailler en interne sur un peu les les
canons par rapport à
ils ont pas cette expérience et donc
c'est mon expérience
essentiellement du Grand Paris mais
aussi de la politique de la ville
je rappelle aussi que j'ai été pendant
15 ans président
d'un département Conseil Général d'abord
et départementale de Loir-et-Cher qui
pardon mais construit des collèges
et aussi un rôle de bâtisseur comme
toutes les collectivités départementales
leçon et donc c'est cette expérience qui
les a intéressé le fait que
[Musique]
je puisse les aider à bâtir un projet de
développement à l'international parce
que leur problématique et la suivante
c'est le grand Moscou comme Anne John
Tay le sait comme député de cette
circonscription avant avance très vite
plus de sanguins ont été inaugurés ils
viennent d'inaugurer une boucle de 71 km
de métro qui est la première ligne même
par rapport à la Chine etc et le
problème c'est que
cette recette qui vient des travaux du
métro va arriver à terme d'ici 2030 et
donc la vision de cette entreprise c'est
de se projeter
à l'international fort de des
savoir-faire de cette entreprise et
ils ont considéré ils m'ont dit
d'ailleurs ils ont considéré que c'était
un atout pour l'entreprise
un atout pour l'entreprise d'avoir
justement un français qui a occupé des
fonctions
importantes et surtout qui a
l'expérience de ce grand projet du Grand
Paris qui très connu à l'international
il faut le savoir dans les autres
capitales et les autres métropoles on
regarde ceux qui se fait sur le sur le
Grand Paris et donc par conséquent voilà
je suis allé récemment à Manille qui est
la sixième métropole mondiale on ne sait
pas toujours et bien
comment Amani quand j'ai échangé avec le
maire de Manille et les autorités de
Manille et ben voilà j'ai pu
montrer le savoir-faire de cette
entreprise donc
quelque part c'est justement cette
expérience qui a paru utile à amis
project
en tout cas c'est ce que me disent les
dirigeants de l'entreprise quand ils
m'ont recruté
merci Monsieur ministre un deuxième
question oui
j'entends vos réponses monsieur le
ministre mais vous disiez tout à l'heure
que vous défendez comme d'autres les
intérêts de l'économie française et je
dois dire moi je suis la première à dire
que nos Français comme vous qui
résidaient à l'étranger rien parce que
vous êtes français vous faites rayonner
le mot France vous faites vibrer le mot
France et vous êtes certainement un des
un des éléments parmi les 2 millions et
demi de Français qui sommes à l'étranger
j'en fais partie nous faisons nous
contribuons à faire exister cette France
et donc vous disiez que vous défendez
les intérêts de l'économie française
mais pardonnez-moi il y a quand même un
truc qui m'interroge quand vous dites
que vous partez à Manille
vous partez à Manille là pour défendre
la société mic et ce qu'elle a fini
pardon et ce qu'elle fait ce que vous
faites pour le développement du Grand
Moscou pour illustrer comment la société
me a pu développer aussi rapidement vous
le dites le grand Moscou là il s'agit
plus du tout d'intérêt français
d'économie française d'entreprises
françaises donc là on est bien d'accord
que là vous travaillez pour l'économie
russe
et bien pas uniquement parce que dans
les projets
justement il y a l'idée à
l'international de s'adosser sur des
groupes je le dis à une jeune t parce
que c'est très important qu'elle le
sache comme député de ses
circonscription à des groupes comme
Vinci ou comme Eiffage pour le moment il
y a eu de concrets
sur Manille c'est juste pour le moment
un prospect mais
justement mon objectif et les projets
c'est d'adosser MIP à des groupes
français notamment Vinci Anne gente se
souvient que le groupe Vinci c'est le
groupe Vinci qui a fait qui vient de
finir l'autoroute qui relie Moscou à
Saint-Pétersbourg donc voilà et donc
l'entreprise MIP est intéressée à des
coopérations parce que
l'idée c'est à l'international de
travailler à des junk Ventures
entre des groupes français alors
évidemment aujourd'hui la période ne le
permet pas mais comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure il y aura on le souhaite tous je
l'espère en tout cas il y aura forcément
un après et on le souhaite parce que
d'abord ce n'est pas dire le retour de
la paix et donc il faudra
retrouver ses coopérations comme on les
avait auparavant
par exemple
j'ai dans cette entreprise
organisée une coopération sexuelle sur
l'élimination des déchets que cette
entreprise traitait sur Moscou donc vous
voyez quand je dis que je défends les
intérêts français je le prouve il y a eu
un marché entre MIP et Suez pour le
traitement de ces échecs voilà donc je
confirme bien la défense des intérêts
économiques français y compris dans des
coopérations qui peuvent se faire non
seulement sur Moscou exemple Suez mais
aussi à l'international même si la
période aujourd'hui est mise entre
parenthèses évidemment du fait des
sanctions notamment il y a pas de
coopération possible pour le moment mais
rien n'indique que ça ne pourra pas se
faire plus tard dans ce que j'appelle
l'après
merci Monsieur ministre moi j'avais une
ou deux dernières questions par rapport
à ce qui a été dit depuis que j'ai posé
les miennes mes premières questions la
première chose est-ce que vous
connaissez monsieur l'ancien député
Jean-Pierre Thomas
qui après avoir été député devenu
président d'un d'une grande entreprise
russe qui produit l'aluminium Rusal ou
Russal c'est pas comme on prononce
vous avez la parole
oui oui je connais très très bien
Jean-Pierre Thomas c'est d'ailleurs le
président Nicolas Sarkozy qui me l'a
présenté
Jean-Pierre Thomas
je l'ai rencontré au salon
économique de Saint Petersbourg quand
j'avais organisé à l'époque avec le
président Sarkozy
une rencontre avec la communauté
d'affaires françaises mais aussi russe à
l'époque alors c'était avant le covid
donc ça doit être de mémoire je veux pas
dire de bêtises donc je sais plus la
date mais ça doit être 2019 ou 2020
merci Monsieur ce vérification permet de
vous reposer d'une manière différente la
question que je vous ai posé au début
sur l'évolution dans le temps et par les
hommes des des relations entre la France
la France entre le personnel politique
français et la Russie notamment le monde
des affaires russes quand même quand on
remonte un certain nombre de pistes de
fil vous-même dans le témoignage que
vous avez apporté sur comment vous avez
rencontré les personnalités qui vous ont
amené à exercer la fonction que vous
occupez aujourd'hui dans l'accueil du
dans l'accueil que vous a demandé
d'exercer François Fillon de
personnalités russes en France puis
le ce que vous a demandé le Quai d'Orsay
à Cannes on a l'impression quand même
que vous qu'on décrit dans l'ordre
plusieurs auditions que notre commission
a mener quand même des relations
économiques très fortes entre les
demandes enfin le mandat de la le mandat
de Nicolas Sarkozy les relations
économiques très fortes entre la France
et la Russie sur des domaines
particuliers et quand même des sociétés
russes qui de près ou loin sont quand
même liés au régime russe par l'énergie
par je suis désolé comme le BTP alors
vous avez d'ailleurs comparé les
entreprises les grandes entreprises
françaises de BTP Bouygues Vinci et
Fages avec cette entreprise russe bon
c'est pas faire offense aux entreprises
françaises de BTP de dire qu'elles ont
des liens de fait assez fort souvent
avec les gouvernements par exemple
Bouygues est intervenu au secours
d'Alstom en 2005 le monter au capital à
la demande de Nicolas Sarkozy je pense
que vous en souvenez que vous le savez
parfaitement c'était pas secret c'était
ça des pignons sur rue et ça fait
d'ailleurs l'objet d'une demande
d'accord de la Commission européenne
donc c'était transparent mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que bon le monde du BTP
est quand même rarement totalement
indépendant du monde de la politique vu
l'ampleur des marchés publics et des
décisions qui sont prises donc ma
question et je me fais de la reposer à
la lumière
dans la décision les sanctions que nous
pouvons prendre contre le régime
pardon vous avez la parole
monsieur le président
vous avez tout dit pardon mais
effectivement vous avez raison de
considérer en tout cas c'est ce que mon
expérience me permet de témoigner raison
de considérer que
il y avait des liens effectivement
très fort mais ces liens comment dire
ils sont les liens d'amitié
franco-russes je me souviens d'une
merveilleuse audition d'Hélène Carrère
d'Encausse devant notre commission des
affaires étrangères de l'Assemblée
nationale c'était d'ailleurs remarquable
ces liens d'amitié de coopération ils
sont multi séculaires avec la Russie
c'est pour ça que c'est ce qui se passe
et
terrible et dramatique pour la relation
franco-russe mais
vraiment je
comme vous l'avez très bien dit
vous-même enfin je vois pas de de je
sais pas comment dire je vois pas de
malice derrière tout ça je pense qu'il y
avait des des liens
économiques et trois qui étaient liés à
ces liens d'amitié multicellulaire aussi
entre la France et la Russie et je sais
pas je
pense à ce que disait
Henry Kissinger encore tout récemment
j'ai vu cette interview remarquable
qu'il a donné à 99 ans ça m'a
impressionné d'ailleurs
où il disait ceci je le cite de points
ouvrez les guillemets
pendant tout mon mandat j'ai essayé de
faire en sorte qu'on ne mette pas
la Russie dans
les mains de la Chine de l'empire
chinois
je trouve ce propos de d'Henri Kissinger
absolument pertinent et je crois qu'il
avait parfaitement raison donc
[Musique]
voilà je veux dire je vois pas là de ce
qu'il y aurait comme un gérant sous
voilà c'est ces liens étaient étaient
très fort je sais pas si vous avez
envisagé de d'inviter l'intérieur
d'encause bon mais c'est très
intéressant de de l'entendre sur sur
toutes ces questions parce qu'elle a une
parfaite connaissance en plus de la
Russie en tout cas je me souviens de
cette audition devant la commission des
affaires étrangères qui étaient
absolument remarquable et qui qui
illustre mieux que tout discours votre
propos sur les liens économiques là
encore je pense que c'était
à l'époque
sous Jacques Chirac comme sous Nicolas
Sarkozy mais pardon ça a perduré aussi
sous la présidence de François Hollande
ou encore de d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est
l'a très bien dit tout à l'heure j'ai
pas une virgule à changer à ce qu'elle a
exprimé
c'est la défense des intérêts
économiques français j'insiste là-dessus
encore une fois c'est il y va de nos
intérêts économiques dans cette
coopération
merci ma dernière question monsieur
ministre vous avez
bien développé vos points sur votre
maintien à votre poste en Russie mais
derrière question vous avez évoqué
évidemment l'invasion russe en Ukraine
d'autres difficultés mais au il y a
aussi des actes vous avez dit on n'est
pas en guerre contre la Russie non mais
il y a quand même des actes d'hostilité
du régime russe ou en tout cas de
groupes qui sont visiblement associés de
de manière maintenant claire et informée
qui mène des attaques notamment
informatiques contre notre pays des
systèmes de demande de rançon de pillage
l'Assemblée nationale même a été victime
d'une attaque informatique certes
bénigne on peut s'en réjouir de au
lendemain du vote ailleurs de la
proposition de résolution de notre
collègue la veille pardon de de votre la
reconnaissance de l'eau de mort comme
comme génocide comme génocide
il y a régulièrement des hôpitaux
français notamment qui qui sont qui sont
attaqués qui mettent quand même en cause
la sécurité sanitaire des patients des
pertes de peut-être des pertes
d'opportunités de soins donc c'est des
bien sûr c'est pas des actes de guerre
tels que le évidemment le peuple
craignant malheureusement les subit mais
il y a quand même des actes d'hostilité
à défaut de pouvoir progrès que ces
gouvernements russes de groupe qui qui
sont liés au régime russe que et ma
question suivante ne voit plus moi c'est
une question ouverte moi je suis pas là
pour juger les cœurs et les reins mais
c'est d'une chose d'avoir des liens avec
des régimes des liens économiques avec
des régimes contestables et la liste est
longue malheureusement la Chine vous
l'avez dit l'Arabie Saoudite on pourrait
faire de la liste est longue des régimes
avec des liens économiques on va dire
réalistes sans avoir d'illusion sur la
nature de leur régime politique mais
c'est une autre chose d'aller travailler
dans ces pays de s'y maintenir même dit
vivre j'imagine aussi d'ailleurs avec
les contraintes démocratiques qui soient
va être quand même bien loin des
libertés publiques que vous avez eu
l'habitude de jouir et de bénéficier en
France donc ma question c'est est-ce que
ça reboule quand même avec la première
la deuxième question que vous avez posée
sur l'évolution dans le temps des
relations entre la France et la Russie
et l'évolution dans le temps du régime
russe à laquelle peut-être vous n'aviez
pas totalement répondu monsieur ministre
c'est est-ce qu'il y a pas un moment
quand même où vous êtes interrogé sur
l'équilibre entre le point que vous avez
fait sur le maintien des relations
économiques avec la Russie et le fait
quand même que votre présence
pour un certain nombre de Français
pouvaient
s'apparenter à une forme de caution du
de ce qui se passait en Russie même si
ce n'est pas votre volonté évidemment
vous avez la parole
oui merci Monsieur présent en
l'occurrence je l'ai démontré expliqué
tout à l'heure ce n'est absolument pas
le cas donc voilà pour le reste ce n'est
pas moi qui dit nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre la Russie c'est le
président de la République
qu'il a
réitéré à plusieurs reprises il a pas
exprimé une seule fois il a dit à
plusieurs reprises et il a raison
d'ailleurs de le dire et de le
réaffirmer pour le reste je ne suis
encore une fois caution de personnes ici
dans le régime je vous l'ai dit je
trouve même qu'on me donne beaucoup plus
d'importance que je n'en ai en réalité
dans la vie quotidienne ici tous les
jours ça je fais mon travail soit en
télétravail comme pendant le covid soit
dans dans l'entreprise qui m'emploie
donc je suis le salarié et voilà je n'ai
pas du tout ni peu ou prou
[Musique]
à faire ou avoir avec ce que ce qui se
passe au plan au plan national de ce
point de vue donc voilà je pense qu'on
donne beaucoup beaucoup plus importantes
voilà
je vous le dis très très sincèrement et
très franchement
je vous remercie monsieur ministre pour
votre sincérité votre votre franchise
comme vous l'avez dit vous-même vous
n'avez pas la langue de bois vous l'avez
dit vous-même bien mieux que moi tout à
l'heure donc monsieur mini va écouter
notre audition touch à sa fin je vous
remercie de votre vous êtes rendus
disponible pour cette audition d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
interrogations et nos questions je
remercie comme vous l'avez fait avec
élégance les services de l'Assemblée
nationale et nos services consulaires
pour l'organisation de cette visio dans
des conditions je le précise pour ceux
qui nous regardent de sécurité optimale
nous n'avons évidemment pas exposé la
sécurité de notre assemblée à une
quelconque menace par cette vision nous
avons pris avec un rapporteur nous avons
veillé à ce que les dispositions soient
prises pour que cette visio soit faite
dans les meilleures conditions donc je
remercie tous ceux qui ont permis que
cette vidéo se fasse dans ces conditions
je vous remercie encore une fois
monsieur le ministre je suspends la
séance pour 5 minutes avant notre autre
audition au revoir monsieur ministre la
séance est suspendue
merci au revoir